crucible is a team-based competitive
shooter published by
amazon and it's totally free from the
two hours we spent with it it looks like
there's a pretty steep learning curve so
here's everything you should know about
the game and what to expect depending on
the hero shooter you're coming from
i'm on fire crucible leans more heavily
on thinking
planning and team tactics than raw
shooting skills players take on the role
of one of 10 hunters
each hunter has an upgrade tree that you
work through mid-match and different
branches of that tree can be set before
a match starts
matches play out slower and more
methodically than other hero shooters
due to the maps being more open and
players having to split their attention
between fighting each other over
objectives or farming the environment
for essence
essence is needed to advance the
hunter's upgrade tree ideally at the
same pace as the enemy team
aiming still important but some hunters
tend to fall strongly into roles and
playing outside of that role may put you
at a disadvantage
for example there were cases where i was
playing as a support player and couldn't
close distance fast enough to do damage
to some of the speedier characters
because
of the early learning curve it's good to
just pick a jack of all trades character
to start off with like summer
once you got your hunter settled you'll
be playing three modes harvester command
is an 8v8 conquest style match and a
great place to start for new players
especially those coming from more
twitchy shooters it's the most
straightforward place to learn the map
which animals to farm
and what different types of plants do
some of them make you invisible some of
them give you buffs
some of them want to eat you it's also a
great mode to test out hunters vs other
hunters
keep in mind whatever hunter you pick is
locked in for the entire match
but multiple people on your team can't
have the same hunter once you got the
hang of that then move on to heart of
the hives mode
played 4v4 this is where you can apply
the knowledge you've learned part of the
hives includes a lot of the base
mechanics of harvester command but also
adds timed events and a different win
state
players compete to grab objectives that
spawn around the map some of these do
things like give you a permanent damage
buff the towers that you capture from
harvester command are also here and they
give you passive essence if taken in
hell
at certain points in a match a hive
appears and the first team to kill it
and
also collect its heart scores so if you
kill the hive but then
die the other team can grab the heart
and get the point three hearts
win the match in this mode you'll need
to communicate with your team because
team cohesion and timing is everything
these matches also sport random
modifiers that you'll need to understand
and take full advantage of
finally there's alpha hunters which
unfortunately we weren't able to play in
our session it's battle royale ish with
eight teams of two fighting to be the
final team standing the difference
is that solo players that have lost a
teammate can join up with other solo
players
but they can also screw them over at the
last minute which sounds kind of evil
some other things we noticed at the
event that you should know about are
there is controller support
although we'd only recommend it with
melee based characters there did appear
to be a battle pass
and definitely an in-game store which
wasn't particularly surprising
the game looks like it'll be a bit rough
for random solo players and it's best
played with a communicating team
overall crucible feels slower and more
nuanced than hero shooters you might be
used to
crucible is out on pc may 20th and can
be found on steam
thanks for watching and for more
crucible coverage head on over to
gamespot
and we're back
[Music]
you